[Music]
all right talking about hockey now
golden knights joining forces with
partners around the community hosting a
food drive
coming up real soon over at city
national arena all the donations helping
three square foot bank are hector mejia
live at city national right now telling
us how you can help out
how's it working hector hey renee good
morning well if you have a few extra
cans in your pantry and you can donate
they will really appreciate it here i
have a can of pork and beans
the food pantry here starts at 10 this
morning and goes on for about a week and
a half
we have video from last year's event
before kovid and once you get here
you'll notice
donation bins across city national arena
to kick things off today the knights are
putting on a party with chants and
cheerleaders
that starts at 10 a.m you can drop off
canned goods until november
13th as nate mentioned all donations
will support three square food bank's
mission to end hunger here in southern
nevada
the non-profit estimates that as many as
450
000 people in the valley do not know
where their next meal is coming from
before the pandemic hit they told us
that number
was down at 270 000 people so they see a
big need right now
and when you donate you can also get a
flu shot this morning
smith's will be here providing flu shots
from 10 am until 2 pm and you can also
get a poster
the first 150 people who donate canned
goods
will get a free poster and i brought
some canned goods from home here i have
some pinto beans some jalapenos and also
some tomato sauce again this food drive
starts today
10 a.m it goes until november 13th
reporting live this morning from city
national arena hector mejia
8 news now good to see hector thank you
very much it's